T
THIS HOUR.
AGAIN, A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
COUNSELOR TO PRESIDENT TRUMP,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KELLYANNE
CONWAY, ALONG WITH FORMER
ARKANSAS GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE.
WOULD YOU HAVE BEEN OFFICIALLY
REPLACED AS THE BEST GOVERNOR IN
THE HISTORY OF STATE OF
ARKANSAS.
YOU KNOW, I HOPE YOU CAN DEAL
WITH THAT REALITY.
THAT'S JUST A FACT.
>> WELL, I WAS JUST PROUD THAT
SARAH, YOU KNOW, KEPT THE
NUMBERS LOW.
SHE DIDN'T TRY TO SHOW OFF OR
ANYTHING.
ONLY GOT 63.5% OF THE VOTE.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU GET WHEN
YOU WON?
>> LET ME JUST SAY IT WAS A
DIFFERENT TIME.
I'M INCREDIBLY PROUD OF HER.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE SAID
OF SARAH.
SHE WILL SATISFY HER SUPPORTERS,
BUT SHE WILL SURPRISE HER
OPPONENTS AND THE PEOPLE WHO DID
NOT VOTE FOR HER.
SHE WILL BE A GOVERNOR FOR ALL
OF THEM.
SHE UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE A TRUE SERVANT LEADER.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT SHE WILL BE
THE BEST GOVERNOR.
I WANT HER TO BE.
I WANT NOTHING LESS THAN THAT.
>> THAT'S WHO YOU ARE, GOVERNOR.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THE REST OF
THE NIGHT LAST NIGHT?
>> DISAPPOINTING.
LET ME BE BLUNT.
I'VE GOT TO GIVE A MEA CULPA.
I WAS GENERALLY PREDICTING THAT
WE WOULD HAVE A RED WAVE, A
TSUNAMI.
I THOUGHT WE'D GET 53, 54 SENATE
SEATS, 230 HOUSE SEATS.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET THERE.
I THINK WE WILL GET THE MAJORITY
IN THE HOUSE.
I STILL THINK WE HAVE A SHOT AT
THE SENATE.
IT WAS NOT THE BIG ELECTION THAT
I HAD HOPED FOR, THAT I
EXPECTED.
BUT I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
I HEARD TED CRUZ SAY A FEW
MOMENTS AGO, AND HE'S EXACTLY
RIGHT, WE'RE BATTLING AN
INCREDIBLE OBSTACLE HERE.
THE HEADWINDS ARE AGAINST US.
TWO BIG THINGS.
IT'S NOT THE DEMOCRATS OR THEIR
MESSAGE.
WE EXPECT THEM TO BE OUR
OPPONENTS.
WE DON'T EXPECT THEM TO SAY WHAT
WE SAY.
THAT'S NOT WHY THEY'RE THERE.
WE HAVE TWO OTHER OPPONENTS WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
ONE IS THE TRADITIONAL MEDIA,
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THEY'RE 90% AGAINST US.
THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING TO SPIN
THINGS AGAINST US.
AND THE OTHER ARE THE
INSTITUTIONS OF THE GOVERNMENT
ITSELF, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THE FBI.
WHEN THOSE TWO ENTITIES GET
TOGETHER, THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
HAVE TO BE GOOD, THEY JUST HAVE
TO STAY OUT OF THE WAY OF THE
INSTITUTIONS OF REAL POWER IN
THIS CAN YOU PLEASE, THE MEDIA
AND THE MOB OF BUREAUCRACY.
IT'S REALLY TOUGH FOR
REPUBLICANS TO BEAT THAT
HEADWIND.
>> Sean: YEAH.
LET ME GET KELLYANNE.
I'M OF THE OPINION THAT PARTISAN
WON LAST NIGHT, THAT YOU COULD
PRETTY MUCH BE A CORPSE, AND IF
YOU HAVE A "D" NEXT TO YOUR
NAME, YOU'LL BE A RUBBER STAMP
FOR THE AGENDA, THAT THE
PARTISANSHIP NEARLY NULLIFIED
ANYTHING ELSE YOU MIGHT STAND
FOR, NO MATTER HOW RADICAL IT
MIGHT BE.
>> NO DOUBT THAT'S TRUE.
THE DEMOCRATS KNEW THAT, SEAN
AND GOVERNOR, GOING INTO THEIR
CLOSING ARGUMENTS.
THEY WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT THE
NEW PLAN TO TACKLE INFLATION OR
TO COMBAT CRIME OR TO BRING US
BACK TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, GET
OUT OF UKRAINE, STOPPING PEOPLE
FROM CROSSING THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, GETTING RID OF FENTANYL
BEING THE NUMBER ONE KILLER.
THEY SAID, WE'RE SCOLDING YOU,
DEMOCRACY IS NOT ON THE BALLOT.
DON'T LET THEM WIN.
THE SMARTER DEMOCRATS ARE
ADMITTING THEY WERE APPEALING TO
THEIR BASE, NOT EARLY, BUT LATE.
THAT'S UNUSUAL.
LATE IN THE GAME POLITICAL
SAVANTS USUALLY TRY TO APPEAL TO
INDEPENDENTS, SWING VOTERS,
LATE-IN-THE-GAME DECIDERS.
I THINK THERE'S INFORMATION TO
TAKE AWAY FROM LAST NIGHT.
ONE IS IN STATES THAT
OBAMA/BIDEN CARRIED TWICE YEARS
AGO, THEY'RE NOW PRETTY DARN
RED.
I'M LOOKING AT OHIO, FLORIDA,
IOWA WAS A CLEAN SWEEP.
WE DON'T TALK ENOUGH ABOUT
GOVERNOR KIM REYNOLDS THERE.
WE HAVE A CLEAN SWEEP OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL RACES.
LEE ZELDIN, BUT IN LOSING HELPED
US WIN FOUR SEATS IN RHODE
ISLAND.
DEMOGRAPHICALLY THERE WAS A
SHIFT OF 13 POINTS AMONG WHITE
SUBURBAN WOMEN.
THAT'S HUGE.
A SHIFT AMONG HISPANICS.
A SHIFT AMONG BLACK VOTERS.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
BECAUSE I THINK DURABILITY
MATTERS.
WE'RE IN A REALIGNMENT TIME.
AND THE DYNAMICS CHANGES OF SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC COHORTS GOING AWAY
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, NOT
SHOWING UP IN ALL THE RACES, IN
THE FINAL TALLIES, BUT OVERALL
NATIONWIDE, THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR
2024.
YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT A CORPSE
THAT DEMOCRATS WILL VOTE FOR A
CORPSE, AND NOT COINCIDENTALLY
TODAY JOE BIDEN HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE AND IN IT HE WAS
ASKED WHAT WOULD YOU DO
DIFFERENTLY.
HE SAID NOTHING.
>> Sean: NOTHING.
>> WHATEVER HAPPENED TODAY WE
GOT CLOSER TO JOE BIDEN BEING
THE NOMINEE ALONG WITH KAMALA
HARRIS IN 2024.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO REGRET
THAT.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO TALK ABOUT
MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE OF MANY
YEARS, SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS.
SOME OF US WERE CLOSE TO TEARS
WATCHING HER TAKE THE
GOVERNORSHIP OF ARKANSAS.
SHE HAS GREAT, DIGNITY, AND
INTELLECT.
SHE DOESN'T NEED TO TAKE THAT
JOB.
SHE HAS A SERVANT'S HEART.
NOT JUST HER FATHER.
ONE OTHER THING ABOUT SARAH, SHE
TOOK SO MANY ARROWS FOR FREEDOM.
SARAH, GOD BLESS YOU, BUT ALSO
REMEMBER SUCCESS FINISHES A LOT
OF SENTENCES.
SHE GETS THE LAST LAUGH FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO TRIED TO TAKE HER
DOWN.
KATIE BRITT AND SARAH SANDERS.
NANCY PELOSI, SHE'LL NEVER HAVE
THE GAVEL.
>> Sean: KELLYANNE, THANK YOU.
GOVERNOR, WE'RE HAPPY FOR YOU,
HAPPY FOR THE PEOPLE OF
ARKANSAS, KNOWING SARAH AS WE
DO, SHE WILL SERVE ALL THE